Schönen Abend.
Ja, guten Abend.
Ich bin der Diensthabender auf dieser Station und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, natürlich. Klar.
Bevor wir über Ihre Aktuellenbeschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Hannah Müller.
Anna mit doppelend?
Ja, genau.
Und Müller und doppelend?
Müller mit Ö, O-Umlaut, nicht U-Umlaut.
Öler, Müller, Möller.
Frau Müller, wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 41.
41. Und wann sind Sie, General Geborgen?
Am 20.09.83.
83.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1.69.
69.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
68 Kilo ungefähr.
68 Kilo. Also Frau Müller, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, seit gestern Abend habe ich ganz starke Bauchschmerzen.
Das fing nach dem Abendessen an.
Es drückt und es so im Oberbauch.
Das strahlt bis in den Rücken rein und bis hier oben in die rechte Schulter.
Das ist immer schlimmer geworden.
Verstehe.
Frau Müller, könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie dünftig, drückend, stechend?
Ja, so ganz heftiger Druck.
Das ist das richtige.
Das kommt immer in so Wellen.
Wie kraftartig, meinen Sie?
Ja, schon so.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala,
wobei ein sehr leichter und sehr starker Schmerz berätet?
Das sind schon starke Schmerzen, sonst wäre ich bestimmt nicht gekommen.
Wo kann man das einordnen?
Vielleicht so bei 7 bis 8 ist das bestimmt.
Sehr heftig, verstehe.
Soll ich Ihnen etwas geben?
Ja, heute Nacht habe ich ein Buskupanzäppchen genommen,
aber das hat eigentlich nicht viel geholfen.
Ich habe heute Morgen noch mal eins genommen,
aber wäre schon gut, wenn Sie mir noch etwas gegen- schmerzen.
Gerne, gerne.
Mach ich das.
Frau Müller, Sie haben erwähnt,
dass diese Schmerzen in den Rücken und in den rechten Schulter ausstrahlen.
Ja.
Und nach wie vielen Stunden oder Minuten sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten?
Dann haben wir gegessen um 7 Uhr und 3-4 Stunden später fing das an.
Okay.
Was haben Sie denn gegessen?
Ja, das war ein bisschen fettig, das gebe ich ja zu.
Es gab Bratkartoffeln und das war natürlich nicht so gut wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe das in letzter Zeit schon mal gehabt,
in den letzten Monaten, wenn ich so richtig deftiges Essen gegessen habe,
dass mir das nicht so gut bekommen ist, aber solche Schmerzen,
wie heute, habe ich das noch wirklich noch nicht erlebt.
Also damals sind die Schmerzen von selbst gefälschten Runden, oder?
Ja, das war dann nur so, ja.
Hat man halt so, hat man mal etwas Verkehrtes gegessen, ja.
Okay, verstehe.
War Ihnen übel oder müssten Sie sich übel?
Jetzt ist mir übel, ja.
Heute Morgen habe ich mich auch einmal übergeben müssen.
Okay.
Und wie sah das Erdbrüffene aus, Frau Müller?
Ja, das, was ich halt so zum Frühstück gegessen habe,
das war schon nicht viel, weil ich eigentlich auch zum Frühstück
keinen Appetit hatte.
Ich habe dann nur ein bisschen Zwieback und Tee getrunken,
der Tee getrunken und Zwieback gegessen und eine Banane.
Und ja, das kam also dann auch wieder raus,
das konnte man schon sehen, dass das das gleiche war.
Okay, das sieht geblieblich, oder bürgeln nicht, oder?
Also, ja, dadurch, dass ich schwarze Tee getrunken habe,
war das halt so rollendig rötlich.
Aber ich kann nicht sagen, also nicht irgendwie,
ich denke, das war das, was ich gegessen habe,
was daraus gekommen ist.
Und sind die Schmerzen gewandert, Frau Müller?
Oder ist es immer gleich im Bereich?
Ich sende die immer an dieser Stelle, ja.
Also so im Oberbau, so ein bisschen auf der rechten Seite, ja.
Okay, rechten Seite.
Und Frau Müller, haben Sie Sud brennen oder Sauerstoßen?
Also eigentlich kenne ich das nicht.
Also jetzt, die saure Gefühl war vor allen Dingen,
dann nach dem Erbrechen.
Aber Sud brennen hatte ich jetzt in letzter Zeit hin und wieder mal, ja.
Okay, Sud brennen haben Sie, okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Sud brennen?
Ach, nur sehr sporadisch, das habe ich nicht regelmäßig.
Eigentlich auch so ein bisschen, wenn ich gesündigt habe,
wenn ich also zu viel gegessen habe,
oder Süßigkeiten gegessen habe.
Also ist da auch einfach, was Sie essen, oder?
Okay, verstehe.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser, das noch mit dem Stuhlgang?
Haben Sie etwas Auffälliges bemerkt?
Ja, also, was ich eigentlich immer habe,
so ein bisschen, dass ich leicht Verstopfung habe.
Und wenn das dann also zu ausgeprägt ist,
dann nehme ich auch manchmal so Tropfen dagegen.
Und dann kommt das besser in den Gang, ja.
Also, was für Eintropfen?
Ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen, das sind so Tropfen gegen Verstopfung.
Okay, okay.
Das ist so etwas, was man kaufen kann in der Apotheke ohne Rezept.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber, oder fühlen Sie Sie fieberig?
Ja, also, heute Morgen habe ich gedacht, dass ich so mich heiß fühle.
Dann habe ich auch tatsächlich mal gemessen.
Und da war die Temperatur so kurz über 38 Grad.
Also nicht richtig hohes Fieber, aber schon ein bisschen erhöht.
Heute Morgen haben Sie das gemessen.
Okay, wo haben Sie das gemessen?
Unter der Achse.
Achse, unter der Achse.
Okay, haben Sie auch nachts schon bei so der Stiftbus vor Möhler?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nur heute Nacht natürlich schlecht geschlafen,
weil das da schon los ging mit diesen Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, verstehe.
Und Sie haben kaum Appetit, oder?
Bitte?
Sie haben kaum Appetit, oder?
Ja, nee, es schmeckt mir gar nicht.
Genau, haben Sie recht, ja.
Okay.
Ja, bei diesen Schmerzen kann man nicht gut essen, ja.
Das ist eigentlich nur so, dass man denkt,
ja, ein bisschen, was muss hier rein?
Und ich dachte auch ein bisschen Flüssigkeit,
aber ja, wir haben es zwar eben auch nicht gut.
Okay.
Boah, Müller, ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass sich Ihre Augen oder Ihr Haut gelblich verwerbt hat?
Nee, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Nein.
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Ja.
Und Frau Müller,
jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Krankenfolge stellen.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen bekannt,
Frau Müller, wie Zuckerkrankheit oder Bruthochdrück?
Ja, also, was ich habe,
schon jahrelang,
eigentlich, dass ich so anfaltsartig eben so Migräneattacken habe.
Das schränkt mich schon manchmal ein bisschen ein.
Und dann hat man irgendwo vor ein paar Jahren festgestellt,
dass ich ein bisschen erhöhte Blutfeldwerte habe.
Und da nehme ich abends so ein Atherostatin,
eine Tablette.
Okay.
Seitdem habe ich mich schon ein bisschen erbaut,
aber ich habe mich schon ein bisschen erbaut,
weil ich mich schon ein bisschen erbaut,
weil ich mir ein bisschen erbaut,
aber ich bekomme so ein bisschen Taskin,
eine Tablette.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Migräne?
Die Migräne, ach, das habe ich schon,
eigentlich, seit der Pubertät,
also schon 25 Jahre.
Sonst ist eigentlich alles okay.
Also okay.
Ja super.
Und Sie haben schon eventuell, dass Sie Atolvastati nehmen.
Also nehmen Sie nur abends, oder?
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Und gegen Migräne nehmen Sie gegen mäßig.
Ja, dann nehme ich, im Anfall, im Alphalsfall sozusagen, nehme ich Treptane.
Treptane, okay.
Okay.
Und damit komme ich dann eigentlich ganz gut zu machen.
Ich dosiere.
Bitte?
Wissen Sie die dosieren?
Also Atolvastati.
Oh, das weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Ja, das kommt ja auch, wie ich immer nur, wenn dann solche Anfälle sind.
Ich versuche das aber schon so im Vorfeld zu nehmen, wenn ich merke, dass es losgeht.
Okay.
Die Dosieren von Atolvastati, wissen Sie?
Das sind 20er, wenn ich richtig weiß.
Ja.
Okay.
Und außer diese zwei Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente
einfach, oder?
Ja, eben diese komischen Verstopfungstropfen da.
Okay.
Und ja, jetzt hatte ich Buscopahanzöpfchen im Haus und da habe ich jetzt eben mal eins genommen.
Ja.
Und wurden Sie schon mal operiert, Frau Müller?
Nee, operiert wurde ich noch nie.
Okay.
Und sind bei Ihnen in Allergien oder Unfälle die Realitäten bekannt, Frau Müller?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich gegen irgendwas allergespinnen bin.
Ah, super.
Okay, prima.
Und rauchen Sie?
Nee, ich rauch, hab noch nie geraucht.
Ah, das ist auch prima.
Okay.
Denken Sie Alkohol, Frau Müller?
Hin und wieder trinke ich Mahnglaswein.
Ja, also wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt oder ja, wenn es ein gutes Essen gibt
oder so, trinke ich gerne Mahnglaswein.
Aber nicht regelmäßig?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Okay, gelegenlich.
Und haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen, Frau Müller?
Oh, nein, nein, nein, da habe ich mich nie dran getraut.
Ja, das ist eine ultimäßige Frage.
Ich muss fragen, Frau Müller.
Bitte nehmen Sie persönlich.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Impfstatt, Frau Müller?
Sind Sie vorständig gegen sowohl Kinderkrankheit,
als auch gegen Corona?
Kinderkrankheiten ist ja schon eine Weile her.
Aber also gegen Corona, klar, wenn ich da geimpft und Grippeimpfung
mache ich auch immer jedes Jahr.
Okay.
Super.
Und Sie sind vorständig gegen, oder?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Sport, Frau Müller?
Ja, also ich gehe wenigstens zweimal eine Woche walken.
Wie?
Walken.
Walken, okay.
Okay.
Und besuchen Sie Ihre Frauen erst im regelmäßig, Frau Müller?
Ja, ja, klar.
Okay, wann war die letzte Untersuchung?
Ich gehe immer im Frühjahr, so im März, April,
da reichte ich letztes Jahr.
War alles in Ordnung?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihre Regel, ist Ihre Monatsblutung regelmäßig, oder?
Ja, ja, ja, kann ich mich so ziemlich drauf verlassen, ja.
Okay, Frau Müller.
Und jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie in
Geschichte, Frau Müller.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, mein Vater ist gestorben, der hatte Leberkrebs.
Der ist wirklich nicht alt geworden.
Leberkrebs.
Okay, wie alt war er?
Ja, der war so Mitte 60.
60, okay.
Wissen Sie, ob Ihr Vater an irgendwelche Kronsche er kann
kommen, geritten hat?
Sonst wüsste ich nicht, nein.
Die Eltern leben auch nicht hier bei mir in der Stadt.
Wir sehen uns nicht so viel, aber das habe ich nicht mitbekommen,
dass er irgendwie jetzt noch etwas anderes hatte.
Okay, und Ihre Mutter?
Ja, da weiß ich, dass sie ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck hat.
Und da hat man jetzt auch im fortgeschrittenen Alter,
hat man diesen Alterszucker festgestellt.
Okay, und haben Sie Geschwister vor, oder?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Ich war ein Zeugin.
Okay, und was machen Sie bei der Ufli, Frau Müller?
Ich bin Kaufmanager angestellte.
Ich arbeite in einer Firma im Büro.
Kaufmanager.
Gestellt, okay.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit, Frau Müller?
Ja, hin und wieder ist es mal stressig,
aber eigentlich gehe ich schon sehr gerne.
Ich arbeite auch keine volle Stundenzahl.
30 Stunden und eigentlich ist das okay.
Okay, und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Und haben Sie Kinder, Frau Müller?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die sind zum Glück gesund, ja.
Okay, super, Frau Müller.
Also, Frau Müller, von meiner Seite habe ich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Wird Ihnen etwas ein, das ich wissen sollte,
oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Jetzt habe ich ja so viele Fragen von Ihnen beantwortet.
Jetzt muss ich überlegen.
Ich will natürlich wissen jetzt, woher es kommt
und was man dagegen tun kann.
Weil ich mir das natürlich eigentlich nicht erlauben kann,
dass ich ausfalle, ja.
Meine Familie braucht mich und bei der Arbeit werde ich gebraucht, ja.
Und die Präsentat kommt, geht immer vor, Frau Müller.
Und Sie haben gut können, uns zu kommen.
Ja, und wir versuchen, die Ursache herauszufinden.
Und wir machen alles, okay.
Ja, und wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Okay, also noch eine Frage, Frau Müller.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, leider nicht abgenommen, aber auch nicht zugenommen.
Okay, also Frau Müller,
jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen und gegebenenfalls
werde ich eine Bauchutterscheid durchführen.
Ja, sobald alle...
Das tut ja nicht weh, ne?
Nein, das ist Schmelztbrot.
Und das ist einfach, einfachste Methode, um die Ursache herauszufinden.
Und sobald die alle davon davor liegen,
kann ich Ihnen etwas genauer sagen, was Ihnen fehlt, Frau Müller.
Okay, ja, das klingt doch gut.
Okay, bitte legen Sie sich auf die Untersuchung-Liga.
Okay.
Hat jemand Fragen an unsere Patienten?
Herr Kollege...
Ah, da kommt was, ja?
Herr Kollege, brauchen Sie Zeit?
Oder möchten Sie weitermachen?
Ja, kann ich...
Ein bisschen Zeit, ich brauche für Sie...
Kann ich Ihnen manchmal noch etwas fragen?
Ja, ich habe Fragen, wenn es gibt Zeit.
Gab es in Ihrer Familie eine Gallensteine Leide?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Zweite Frage ist, haben Sie die Veränderung der Farbe,
der Stuhl, der Urin bemerkt?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, ja.
Also kann ich nicht zu sagen...
Es fällt ja auch alles immer in die Toilette und dann ist es weg.
Also ich habe da nichts bemerkt, dass da irgendetwas anders war.
Okay.
Haben Sie Atembeschwerden oder Herzbeschwerden?
Herzstörbern, Herzrasen oder Atemnot?
Nee, nee, also das Einzige, was jetzt so komisch war,
dass eben diese Schmerzen so heftig waren
und dass die so ausgestrahlt haben,
das hat mir auch so ein bisschen Angst gemacht, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, das war meine Frage.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber und haben Sie Schüttelfrost oder Nachtweiß?
Hat er gefragt, habe ich Verneinschüttelfrost oder Nachtweiß,
aber ich habe gesagt, dass ich mich heute Morgen fieberig gefühlt habe
und dass die Temperatur etwas über 38 war, axiolär im Messer.
Könnte?
Ja.
Gut.
Okay.
Schönen Abend Herr Obererstin.
Ich habe ja eine neue Patientin aufgenommen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie kurzer Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie haben Sie gesehen?
Ja, sie heißt Hannah Möhler.
Sie ist 41 Jahre alt, 1,69 m groß und 18,60 kg schwer.
Sie hat sich bei uns wegen seit gestern Abend bestehender,
drückender, krampfartige epigastische Schmerzen vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in den Rücken,
sowie in den rechten Schutters.
Die Schmerzen legen auf eine Schmerzskala
bei 7 bis 8 von 10.
Und die Patientin berichtet, dass die Schmerzen
3 bis 4 Stunden nach dem Verzehr von viertiger Essen aufgetreten sind.
Ja, okay.
Und dagegen haben die Patienten Buscopansäbchen eingenommen.
Das hat ihm nicht, das hat er nicht geholfen.
Und Aspegleibsymptome, er nannte die Patienten nauseher.
Es ist einmalig.
Also das besteht aus, was sie getrunken hat.
Ja, also hat sie wieder erkannt sozusagen.
Ja, klar.
Und außerdem klackte sie über Ruktus, Sortbrennen und Obstubation.
Sie habe auch Fieber, sie hat 38° gemessen, also unter der Achsel.
Achsel?
Ja, und Schmerzbedingte Schlafstörung hat die Patienten.
Und Appetenz auch.
In der Bezahnung.
Leider die Patienten seit 25 Jahren an Migräne
und seit 2 bis 3 Jahren an Hypercholestänomie.
Und dagegen nehme die Patienten Atorvastatin 20 mg einmal abends ein
und auch Triptan, nehme sie, aber dessen Dosierung weißt die Patienten nicht.
Und sie wurde nie operiert.
Und weder Alligin noch Unfältiglichkeiten hat die Patienten.
Sie ist nicht Raucherin.
Der Alkoholkonsum ist ein Glas Wein gelegentlich.
Und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Der Impfstatus ist vollständig.
Und sie treibt regelmäßig Sport.
Und die genecologische Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Und in der Familienanamnese ergab sich, dass die Vater an Leberkarzinom
im Alter von 60 verstorben ist.
Und die Mutter leider an Atelierle Hypertony und Diabetes Melutotyp 2.
Und sie ist Kaufmanagerin, Angestellte von Beruf und sie ist verheiratet
und habe zwei gesunde Kinder.
Aufgrund der anatomistischen Angaben gehe ich von einer Holosystitis aus.
Die finanziellen Diagnostischen kommen auch Hololithiasis,
Pachratitis,
Bucchusmentiocili,
in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zuerst die
Patientin körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde zuerst die Schmerzlokalisation bestimmen.
Ja.
Und zuerst werde ich die Darngeräusche abhören,
ob sie versteckt oder vermindert sind.
Und danach werde ich den Bauch abtasten.
Ich habe schon gesagt, um die Schmerzlokalisation zu bestimmen.
Und zu überprüfen, ob Druckschmerzen oder Losserschmerzen vorliegen.
Und danach werde ich die Blut abnehmen.
Bei der Blutuntersuchung werde ich Blutbild, BSC, CRP, Amylase, Lipase,
Colestaswetter, wie direktes und indirektes Glubin bestimmen.
Ja, okay.
Und das Blutgebänderverfahren werde ich zuerst eine Abtomasonografie
abnehmen.
Ja, das erwarten Sie?
Also, Galenblase, Verdickung werde ich auch warten.
Oder werde ich auch eine Stein, vielleicht kann ich es sehen.
Ja, genau.
Wenn er sich dann darstellt, ja.
Und ebenfalls werde ich eine Bauch-CT oder MRT,
eine Bauch-CT durchführen, vielleicht eine Bankreatitis
auszuschließen.
Ja, vielleicht kann ich mit Otterstall nicht gut beurteilen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen,
werde ich die Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Larus carens werde ich empfehlen.
Verordnen, ja.
Verordnen und Flüssigkeit zu führen.
Ja.
Und beim Nachweis.
Flüssigkeit zuvor, welcher Weg?
Also, ich werde zuerst Zugang legen.
Ja, dann werde ich Flüssigkeit zu führen.
Ja, sehr gut. Zugange legen, ja.
Beim Nachweis von Infektionen erregern,
werde ich eine antibioterapie einleiten.
Gut, ja.
Wenn die Usage eine Stein wäre, würde ich eine
ELCP oder Operation empfehlen.
Ja, sehr gut, okay.
Ja, ich bin gespannt,
wie es bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Wenn die Patientin aufgenommen wird,
schauen wir die Nachher zusammen noch an.
Ja, das mache ich gerne.
Sie schnell sind Sie.
Wir haben noch so viel Zeit über.
Wenn ich gleich meine Überkritik übergehen darf,
das war sehr schön.
Ich habe noch eine Frage als Aufbericht.
Das würde ich sagen sehr vollständig.
Eine Winzigkeit ist mir aufgefallen bei Ihrer Sprache.
Sie haben bei den Fragen, waren sie sehr variabel,
haben sehr schön verschiedene Formulierungen gewählt,
um irgendwelche Sachen nachzufragen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Da ist mir das auch sprachlich nicht so aufgefallen.
Aber wenn Sie beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch
und Sie einen volllaufenden Text sprechen,
machen Sie etwas Witziges.
Sie machen die Satzmelodie,
lassen Sie so auf einer Ebene.
Wir machen das, ja.
Wir machen einen Satz und fangen an
und gehen dann mit der Stimme runter zum Punkt.
Sie bleiben immer oben.
Man denkt immer, jetzt geht es weiter,
jetzt erzählt er noch irgendwas.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Ihnen das schon mal jemand gesagt hat.
Mir ist es jetzt extrem aufgefallen.
Ich habe mir auf meinem Zettel ein Pfeil gewählt.
Das ist das, was mir ein bisschen aufgefallen ist.
Als ich sehr kritisch zugehört habe,
habe ich gemerkt, ziemlich viele As.
Ob es eine Katastrophe ist in der Prüfung,
ich glaube nicht.
Wir machen es alle,
wir machen es nicht alle so ausgeprägt,
aber ein bisschen machen es alle.
Weil uns immer mal wieder ein Wort fehlt
oder weil wir nicht schnell oder flüssig genug sprechen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt wirklich extrem ist bei Ihnen.
Es ist mir nur aufgefallen, dass es auch da ist.
Aber die Verständlichkeit,
wenn Sie fortlaufen sprechen,
würde wirklich gewinnen,
wenn Sie sich ein bisschen Zeit lassen
und diese Satzmelodie ein bisschen einüben.
Das ist nur so ein Tipp.
Dazu muss man selber vielleicht mal sich etwas vorlesen
oder so, damit man das merkt.
Bei Fragen, klar, gehen wir am Ende mit der Stimme hoch.
Aber sonst machen wir es eigentlich schon ziemlich ausgeprägt,
dass wir die Stimme ansteigen lassen zur Satzmitte
und dann runtergehen.
Es hört sich leicht dazu
und man versteht besser, was Sie erklären wollen.
Schön fand ich, Sie haben gut Fachbegriffe einfließen lassen
im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Sie haben sich an Ihren Farbplanen gehalten,
so wie Sie gefragt haben.
Sie haben auch konsequent die Geschichte erzählt
und die Angaben gemacht.
Ich würde sagen, damit können Sie problemlos zur Prüfung antreten.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen netten Fall.
Wann ist es?
Also 16. Dezember.
Sie könnten morgen gehen, das vereint man.
Gut. Ja, mir hat es gut gefallen.
Ich hoffe, Sie haben sich auch wohl gefühlt
und die anderen sind hoffentlich auch einverstanden.
Dr. Gündis ist nicht da,
er hat immer ein paar kritische Anmerkungen.
Aber was sagen die anderen Kollegen?
Ja, hier, guck mal, Dr. Gündis, ist sehr hip-prall.
Er war auch klasse, oder?
Er war auch klasse, er war auch richtig gut, oder?
Ja, genau.
Er scheint schon bereit für Prüfung.
Ich glaube, Sie bestanden die Prüfung.
Ja, Sie sehen, die anderen sagen das auch.
Er hat gut gemacht.
Ja, wir sehen uns, heute ist schon,
ich bin so durcheinander mit den Wochentagen,
heute ist erst Dienstag.
Heute ist schon Donnerstag.
Klar, wir sehen uns am Dienstag.
Wir sehen uns am Dienstag wieder.
Lassen Sie es sich so lange gut gehen,
haben Sie ein spannendes Wochenende.
Ja.